We saw at the end of the last lesson that we could come up with a function for
the area of a rectangle by saying that A of l,w equals lw. The product of the
length and width of any rectangle. Well, in our case, l and w are going to be
represented by a different variable, actually. They're both written already in
terms of x. I'm going to call this the length and this width. So in our case the
length is actually just x plus x, or 2x plus 3. Remember that the m here stands
for meters, not a variable. And the width is just 2x. If we want to apply this
out we get 4x squared plus 6x squared meters. So instead of writing the area as
a function of length and width, instead we're writing it as a function of x now.
It's function that only involves only one variable since we had both of these
original variables in terms of the same third variable.